and every six or 12 months he moved to a
new club it's a new environment and it
takes time to to build up a trust with
other players and I just couldn't make
good enough friends to say look this is
who I am and gradually come out that
never happened and there were moments in
the dressing room and I don't know
whether you've experienced this
when when players talked about it
hypothetically is there a gay football
player what would you do if if we had a
gay teammate and some of the things have
been said have were low moments for me
because suddenly players say you know if
we ever gave teammate I wouldn't shower
with him you know I wouldn't get changed
in the dressing room I was like really
is that what you would do and there were
some other things that have been said
that I thought you know I wouldn't want
to be open again in the stressing room
and that was was very frustrating to say
that just proves that the the dressing
room can be a tough environment